[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 24th of
march i'm john connolly the spectators
news editor and i'll be your host this
week
on this week's show
rishi sunat gave his spring statement on
wednesday the chancellor boasted that he
was unveiling the largest single tax cut
in a decade while the obr said living
standards would suffer from the biggest
fall since records began in the 1950s
the spectators kate andrews james
forsyth and katie bulls will talk us
through the chancellor's statement
it's been four weeks since the russian
invasion of ukraine began and us
intelligence officials said the invasion
has stalled with putin's forces still
struggling to take key cities what's the
full story we'll find out with mark
galiotti and dmitry alpirovic
in this week's cover story o matthews
looks at how recep air diane the
president of turkey has become the key
middleman between putin and the west
he'll be on to explain and discuss
turkey's dilemma alongside hannah
lucinda smith
and finally is china's zero covered
strategy falling apart
matt ridley writes in this week's
magazine that omicron is spreading
through the country like a bushfire
he'll be on the show with cinderelu
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit
candoowealth.com to find out
more remember as well to subscribe to
our youtube channel too click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
rishi sooner gave his spring statement
in the comments yesterday announcing
measures which he said would ease the
cost of living crisis will they i'm
joined now by the spectators economics
editor kate andrews our political editor
james forsyth and our deputy political
editor katie balls
james katie and kate thank you for
coming on spectator tv
right kate to start us off the
chancellor promised before this spring
statement or wanted us to think at least
that he was now a low tax cutting tory
do you think he managed to succeed this
week
well if you look at the newspaper
headlines this morning i think it's
actually going to be a rough ride for
rishi sunak over the next few weeks and
months because the truth is that the
cost of living squeeze is only going to
worsen inflation is only going to go up
interest rates are going to go up and
the chancellor has been very clear for
months now that he can't lift all the
pain he can't lift every bit of
financial burden that's going to fall on
people's shoulders but i think for a lot
of people out there it's only going to
get worse
the difficulty is that while he has
certainly announced tax cuts in the
spring statement fuel duty is going to
fall by 5p the national insurance
threshold has risen by almost 3 000
pounds it's the biggest threshold raise
on record he and he's going to be
cutting income tax as well by 2024 he
says he's going to reduce the basic rate
from 20p to 19p
the other tax hikes that he's brought in
previously freezing personal allowance
thresholds corporation tax the national
insurance levy for those who will still
be paying it outweigh what he's cut
so you can look at his tax cuts and
certainly say yes he is a tax cutting
chancellor but you can also look at the
tax raises and point out that in a few
years time the tax burden is actually
going to be at a 77-year high up from a
71-year high
so a lot of it is the narrative that you
want to craft and the question behind
all this is is what is rishi sinha
really trying to achieve and i think
he's trying to bring
some fiscally responsible ideas back to
his government that actually we can't
keep spending money and cutting taxes
and have everything we want without
saying how we're going to pay for it
that's why he doubled down on that ni
hike he said if you want more money for
health and social care and that's
long-term spending you can't borrow it
it's got to come from taxes but he's
also thinking about the money that he
has to hold back
as interest rates and inflation continue
to go up because what we're now paying
to service the debt around 83 billion
pounds a year that's just to pay the
interest on money we've already borrowed
is four times higher than it was last
year it's certainly bigger than what we
spend on defense overall in this country
these are payments that um we we can't
get around we we have to pay them
and it's an incredible sum of money so
he's trying to juggle all of these
things and i think the difficulty for
the chancellor is that
in a way he's made a lot of people
somewhat happy but he's made very few
people completely happy
and katie kate mentioned the front pages
there how has the spring statement been
received generally do you think
i would say pretty negatively um i think
you can caveat and say if you're facing
uh the worst cost of living crisis in
records since 1950 which is the obr's
projection and
what is it that the government could do
to really
make that not an issue could they could
they really get rid of the whole thing
and therefore
this is fairly caveated but if you look
at the front pages lots were picking up
on that point by the obr
and then you have a situation where uh
those left leaning papers uh
highlighting the fact that they don't
think that rich student has done enough
for the vulnerable there was nothing new
on benefits when it came to the spring
statement and then on the right you have
papers of ultimately such as the daily
mail
calling for more tax cuts telegraph
pretty negative
and therefore you can see that rishi
seneca is trying to say he's a tax
cutter as kate points out when you look
at the figures um
that is questionable basically trying to
signal this um but i think the issue is
it's not enough for the right and yet
you're still seeing a situation where
for example
uh rishi sunex spoke to tory mps after
the spring statement in private a
meeting on the 22 committee and i would
say to be honest that
from those in the room and there were
only around 50 mps there because it was
a one-line whip that um
it had
a mixed reception i wouldn't say it was
nearly as negative from the various
people i've spoken to there as the
papers are you had some uh tory grundy's
actually praising richie nick in terms
of the threshold and um
the plan for an income tax cut you know
some red wall mps saying the threshold
changing on national insurance was a
good thing it was going to make this
national insurance like a lot less
painful their constituents but
ultimately you couldn't get around cost
of living and john redwood um the tory
mp was saying that the treasury was
massively underestimating the cost of
living and you were going to need to
have many more tax cuts in order to fix
this so you can see that rishi sunik is
being pushed to go further and i think
the question is um in the coming months
as pressure grows we expect to see more
in terms of energy i would imagine by
the autumn when it gets to the budget
and but is he going to come into
pressure anymore and things like
universal credit and bring that in line
of inflation i would uh say probably yes
james do you think rich sunak's in a bit
of an impossible position here and he
perhaps doesn't have as much wriggle
room as some of his critics say
well the truth is that the problem of
inflation is that there are no winners
from it there are only losers it makes
everyone poorer so if you're in an
environment where inflation is going to
hit a 40-year high as the obr predicts
politics is going to become very
scratchy and very difficult you know
governments essentially have four
options when it comes to to raising
revenue
they can borrow the money and for all
the reasons that that k andrews just
articulated uh that is an increasingly
unappealing prospect right now because
the cost of servicing that debt is going
up you can raise taxes and as katy paul
said you know with taxes at a 70 or dr
high that is not an appealing prospect
that leaves you just two other options
one is spending restraint uh and the
other is growth and you know the truth
is the uk economy has grown very slowly
and very sluggishly since the financial
crisis before uh in the first years
before the crash productivity grew at
2.2 percent a year on average uh in the
uh since the crash it's grown at a
measly 0.4 percent and i think that
means that you know we are entering into
a new period of spending restraint
and that that is going to be very
difficult techy politics you you look at
the fact that uh departments weren't
compensated for the fact that inflation
is higher now than it was in october and
that's in this statement and i think
that points you to uh below inflation
pay rises for lots of public sector
professionals that is going to be
politically difficult uh especially for
those public sector professionals who
felt feel that you know they
particularly bore the brunt of the
pandemic in in terms of workload so i i
think politics is going to become very
difficult but i mean that is an
inevitable consequence of what happens
when inflation gets going in the way
that it is and it is just worth
remembering that you know how afraid of
inflation politicians used to be and i
think that this generation of uh both
central bankers and politicians
were too complacent about the risks of
inflation and i mean inflation is now up
and running and it is very difficult to
control once that is the case
i mean kate in in his statement rishi
sooner mentioned the fact that recent
inflation figures hadn't taken into
consideration the energy cap do you
think things are going to get worse for
the economy essentially and for the
treasury by extension almost certainly
um what's happened with the economic
sanctions against russia while morally
correct are going to have a really big
economic impact here at home and most of
europe trying to wean itself off of
russian energy means that
prices are going to be hiked for us
because there's going to be more
competition
for the gas and imports that we've been
bringing in
one of the things about the energy price
cap which i think has more or less been
disastrous for uk energy policy it's put
dozens and dozens of companies out of
business
one of the things about it at least for
the treasury is that they will have some
idea the off gem will
announce in october uh the extent to
which that price cap is lifting further
so they will know how much support
people need and because that isn't
happening again until the autumn that
did take the pressure off of hershey
cenac in this budget to announce more
direct support but as james was pointing
out in our coffee house shots live event
last night the treasury just a month ago
dedicated 9 billion pounds to try to
support people especially the most
vulnerable through this most recent
energy price cap lift which is coming in
april dishing out hundreds of pounds for
the vast majority of households to help
ease the burden of those bills that is a
huge a colossal sum of money and it's
almost gone out the window people have
almost forgotten about it asking you
know what's the next subsidy going to be
and and the really hard truth here it's
not that we're out of money it's that
we're now with inflation going as high
as it is with interest rates set to rise
further we're now having to talk about
tough trade-offs you can't just keep
borrowing and borrowing and borrowing
and saying that you're going to pay it
back at a later date because just the
interest payments now
are they're not crippling us but they
certainly could soon i mean 83 billion
pounds just to service the debt is you
know a mind-boggling amount of money you
don't get new hospital beds for that you
don't get new nurses or doctors you're
just paying off money that you've
already borrowed um so you know if you
want to help people with their energy
bills come autumn it's going to be
another tough conversation about
trade-offs where that money comes from
does it come from tax hikes are we going
to spend a little less in other areas to
help the most vulnerable with their
bills in october
but this is the inevitable consequence
of
two years of global economies locking
down and then kick-starting and the
shortages and the labor crunches that
have come from that it's the consequence
of economic sanctions as i said before
the right thing to do but still painful
there are costs attached to all these
things and i think you know if you are
going to point to the failure of this
government in communication perhaps one
of the things you point out is that
people seem terribly surprised from this
mini statement this this spring
statement mini budget that the
chancellor hasn't gone all out like a
furlough scheme and supported everybody
through every economic pain that's about
to come and perhaps the prime minister
in particular should have been more
honest with the public several months
ago that times were going to get tough i
think people are really quite surprised
by this but
it was inevitably going to happen to
some extent
in casey in tough economic times it does
tend to be the opposition who benefits
um do you get any sense that labour are
making inroads with the sort of the
country's economic difficulties at the
moment
i think it's interesting looking at the
polling about um who voters trust most
in the economy there is one which i
think puts uh rachel reeves and kirsten
one percent now ahead of richie sunak
and boris johnson now i think that is
too small a lead to take you know
labor out in front by any means but i
think it does just show you in the sense
that one of the things that really hurts
labor and elections the fact they're not
trusted on the economy so you can see
how the cost of living crisis the fact
that snap polls yesterday i think it was
a yougov snapple and
by some margin people thought that rishi
said i needed to do more you can see how
they can get something from this crisis
and can perhaps use it um whether or not
it's enhancing their economic reputation
on their own merit or more just
watching the tories take a dent and
trying to move it in that sense and you
can see how they potentially work around
that i think that
also if you look at the conversations i
mean at the moment labour are not coming
up with a full plan for funding and how
they're gonna um you know
how they would ultimately deal with the
cost of living they talk a lot about a
windfall tax and the idea that would
cover you know the various things we're
talking about that would only be one
part of it so i think as we get closer
to the next election and later have to
explain what their spending plan is
they'll come on to scrutiny too because
as for the many reasons that we've just
had out loan from both james and kate um
the answer of more borrowing and more
taxes you know there are very few
appetizing options right now when it
comes to um the fiscal plan
and james it's perhaps noticeable that
one of the rabbits that rishi sunnah
pulled out of his hat was an income tax
cut that scheduled for 2024. do you
think that's quite politically astute
ahead of any general election
yeah and i think it is also designed to
send a message saying look you know you
can have a cut there can be a cotton
income tax
if uh there is uh a lid is kept on extra
spending it is essentially saying you
know but there there is there is a
purpose to this fiscal discipline which
is an attempt to cut the basic rate of
income tax by april 2024 which is yeah
and it i don't think it's entirely a
coincidence but two of the most likely
dates for the next election are may 2024
and september 2024. um i think one other
thing i would say is that you know lots
of speculation about when the next
election is going to be when you look at
these inflation forecasts i think they
they definitely suggest that an election
in 2024 is more likely than 2023 in that
it is going to take about 12 to 18
months for this inflation to pass
through the system
and if you were the governing party you
would want to give back inflation and as
much time as possible to pass through
the system before you went to the
country
thank you james and thank you kate and
katie
russia's invasion of ukraine continues
with putin's forces bombarding the city
of mariopol as russia look to take their
first major ukrainian city will it fall
and with the invasion flagging what's
the russian leader's plan i'm joined now
by dmitry alpirovic as security expert
and co-founder of the silverado policy
accelerator think tank in washington and
mark gagliatti a spectator contributor
and director of mayak intelligence
dmitry mark thank you for joining us on
spect spectator tv today
um dimitri could you start us off first
of all by giving us a bit of an update
on the state of play when it comes to
the war and the russian invasion ukraine
and sort of the states play for both
sides i guess
well by and large the campaign on the
russian side is quite stalled so many of
their access of advance their attempts
to surround kiev have stalled and in
fact due to ukrainian counter-offensive
they've actually been pushed back out of
some of the suburbs um their attempts to
move on odessa through mikalive or get
around nikolai have also been pushed
back by ukrainian resistance the one
area where they're making progress is
mariupo they've been able to surround
the city they've been able to uh bomb it
into oblivion of course and uh
increasingly taking territory there if
there's one city that is in danger of
falling in the coming days it is
mariopol and uh once it falls if it
falls they'll be able to take some of
those forces and potentially move them
further north and surround the
ukrainian troops or in the donbass
region so things aren't necessarily
great for the ukrainians but the
russians are running into a lot of
problems i'll tell you uh there was a
intercept alleged intercept released by
ukrainian forces this week
which is a call between a commander on
the ground uh near mikaliv area in the
south talking to their superiors in
russia and complaining that 50 of the
troops have frostbite on their feet uh
there have been friendly fire incidents
where their own troops have been bombed
through airstrikes by russian planes and
potentially artillery as well that they
don't have body armor they don't have
hot food because they don't have a hot
stove so morale is just a complete
disaster and they're saying that the tv
is reporting russian tv that they're
making a lot of progress and taking a
lot of territory but he says we're just
driving through not clearing villages
and then we end up fighting essentially
a 360 degree battle because they're
attacking us from everywhere them
they've been ukrainians of course and
mark it was interesting the u.s
secretary of defense sort of gave a
similar assessment this week he said
also said that the russian advance has
stalled do you agree with that
assessment as well
yeah absolutely i mean i think it's
clear that for a variety of reasons
much to do with the
traditional russian problem of being
more teeth and tail
in other words not really addressing the
logistical backup um the the russians
are in a position where they can launch
local offensives and counter offenses on
a relatively small scale but as dmitry
said except around mariupol they're not
really in a position to actually mount
any major offenses now obviously they're
doing what they can to try and untangle
their supply issues and we shouldn't get
complacent
but for the moment these kind of grand
notion of a sweep across ukraine or at
least up to the nipper river that's
clearly not happening and going further
than that mark do you think there's any
chance that they've been some
assessments this week that ukraine might
actually win the war do you think that
goes too far or is that is that credible
i'm going to be incredibly irritatingly
academic here and say depends what you
mean by when
if you mean are the ukrainians going to
chase every russian out of their country
tail between their legs roll back into
crimea and the donbass regions no i
don't think that's likely to happen at
all if nothing else the point is at the
moment ukrainians have all the advantage
of being on the defense
as soon as they actually started to move
offensively they would actually
basically lay themselves open to some of
the areas in which the russians actually
have particular capabilities but more to
the point there is an element of
exhaustion that will inevitably creep in
i mean even and it is not exhausting in
the sense of people being tired that
clearly people are tired because we've
seen the ukrainians being willing to
push themselves to to extreme limits
it's just a point about you know at a
certain point
you need to have you know a thorough
replenishment of units you need to
actually have more material and it's not
just simply a question of another bunch
of rockets being sort of passed across
the border and such like so i think what
we are seeing is in many ways the
ukrainians are winning by denying the
russians any kind of victory
the prospect for actually the ukrainians
being able to push the russians back
locally is absolutely the case
but this is a war that is going to end
because of some kind of peace deal or
some kind of stalemate it's not going to
see a knockout blow by either side
and you know if i can add the one place
i'm watching very closely is the city of
hersone the one major uh ukrainian city
that the russians have been able to take
over in the early stages of the campaign
and we're seeing a lot of civil
disobedience among the population there
they're coming out in protest there's a
big protest this past weekend they're
blocking traffic uh for russian military
interest guardia national guard units so
they're encountering a lot of local
resistance not yet violent even in the
one place that they've been able to take
over which doesn't bode well for them
being able to control this country even
if they somehow manage to take it over
dimitri i know you mentioned their
pressure on the ukrainian side are we
also going to see pressure on the
russian side i know we've seen
unconfirmed reports of around 10 000
deaths in the russian army is this going
to play significant pressure on putin
essentially when the bodies start coming
home
i don't think so and i would be very
careful about those estimates i think
they're probably a little bit too high
in terms of casualties on the russian
side but you also have to remember that
uh the propaganda machine is operating
in full force in russia much of that
information is not filtering down to the
people a lot of the people that are
fighting this war are actually ethnic
minorities there's a lot of chechens
from kaderos units they're fighting the
tough fight in mariopo right now
there's a lot of people from central
asia that are contractors in the
military so um it's unfortunate to say
this but the majority of the russian
public won't care a whole lot about
those casualties um because just
inherent racism in the society
so i don't think that we're anywhere
close to the point where the casualties
will have an impact on their um uh popul
of the worst popularity back home
and mark we mentioned mario poll back
there and the city has been facing a
huge bombardment in recent days and
weeks do you think this is a sign of a
sort of changing russian strategy which
is just going to be focused on
humanitarian bombings essentially
targeting cities and we're going to see
that more widely now across ukraine do
you think
yes i mean it's a an inevitable and
depressing uh side effect of the fact
that their initial
fantastic notions of a rapid blitzkrieg
that will have the whole country falling
into their lap has failed
now they're having to do it by a sort of
thuggish but
methodical way which is after all i mean
we shouldn't be surprised because this
is what they did in chechnya this is
what they've been doing in syria that
actually
urban combat is very difficult it
requires high levels of skills and
coordination amongst your forces if
you're going to go in
to places where
every basement every rooftop could be
housing a sniper or someone who's going
to drop a molotov cocktail on you
it is i'm sad to say a lot easier to
bomb the place into rubble and then to
plant your flag on top
and that is essentially the approach
we're taking i mean from from the
russians point of view after all
to put it very bluntly they're looking
to conquer parts of ukraine they don't
need the ukrainians
and therefore i think the same way as we
may well see actually increased use of
pressure and humanitarian corridors
being used precisely for
cleansing the area of as they would say
the population hesitate to use the word
ethnic cleansing because that has some
very particular implications but
certainly depopulating sort of areas
which will allow the russians greater
opportunities to control them so
unfortunately madupol
is probably a harbinger of the future if
the russians are to move on to other
cities
i have to say we're starting to see that
particularly in that allegedly
intercepted call the officer is saying
that their initial orders were not to
destroy the infrastructure and he's
saying we can't win here without
pummeling everything into the dirt
including the civilians that was
literally the quote from this officer in
this alleged intercepted call so i think
the tougher the problem uh becomes for
them the more brutal they will become in
response
and dmitry are you seeing any signs that
we're getting closer to a negotiated end
to the war or do you think that's still
too far too far off to sort of
contemplate
you know i'm actually getting very
pessimistic on a negotiated outcome here
we could potentially have a limited
ceasefire because both sides are quite
exhausted and they need to resupply and
take a break but i don't see a lasting
negotiated settlement in part because
the more territory that the russians are
taking like her son if they take
mariopol
and being able to connect on boss to
crimea via this
land bridge and so forth the less likely
i think it becomes that putin will
actually relinquish that territory
and he will demand of course
that territory to be joined to the lnr
and dnr statelets that he is recognized
now in the donbass region and
that's just not going to be palatable to
zelinski even if he somehow wanted to
make a deal
he just could not sign anything like
that without being run out of town by
his own people so i actually think that
uh the likelihood of a peaceful
settlement here is is very unlikely and
becoming less so by each day
i think i just add in there in some ways
i'm a little bit more um in cautiously
and
unexpectedly optimistic
only very very slightly because i think
although i agree absolutely with um this
notion that
the russian territorial games they'll
want to hold on to and zielinski
absolutely would not but on the other
hand what i think is interesting is we
must remember these are two wars being
fought there is a war being fought on
the battlefield in ukraine and then
there is a wider economic war being
waged against russia and i mean we're
already beginning to see that the damage
being done the the empty shells that the
people unable to get medicines and the
real concern amongst the technocrats now
the trouble is obviously the technocrats
who kind of run the economy and such
like they're not putin's in a circle i
mean his basic
interest in them is just simply their
job is to make sure everything runs and
there is the money for the things that
putin wants to happen
but they're clearly trying to indicate
to the boss that in fact this is not
just simply a situation in which dictat
will be able to get anywhere so i mean
there is a chance that precisely the the
scarring that is being done to the
russian economy and the potential
political implications of that
will actually induce putin to be a
little bit more flexible in terms of
actually a resolution on the battlefield
i only throw that out as a possibility
well i think we're a long way away from
being able to say that we see a deal in
sight but that that is where you know if
there is going to be a peace deal it is
going to be because of the intersection
of these two wars
and demetrius i think the problem though
mark is that uh and i completely agree
with you the economic damage that's been
done to russia is just absolutely
massive but i bet you that putin
probably with some reason thinks that
those sanctions and not even the
sanctions but the companies that pulled
out they're not coming back and and the
sanctions are not uh going away in fact
the history shows that sanctions are
rarely uh being dropped on countries
once we place them upon um
upon them and certainly that's been the
case in russia so uh i have a feeling
that he's thinking he's all in he's
already paid the price and now he has to
get something for it
that's true and i think therefore in a
way the russians would expect some kind
of indications on sanctions to be part
of any peace deal which again makes it a
lot more complex because the ukrainians
can agree what the ukrainians can agree
but they can't speak for the western
sanctions so many moving parts
i mean dmitry you mentioned when you
were last on the show that you thought
the chance of a palace coup against
putin was i think close to zero you said
do you still stand by that or do you
think that the dial is shifted at all
there
i do i i mean you know of course you
know coups happen uh in a way that's
very unpredictable and and we wake up
and find out that a coup has occurred
without much warning in many countries
um you know in russia
i think if there's going to be a coup it
would have to come from the intelligence
services and they're still quite loyal
to him you know many of the sort of
middle uh layer management may think the
boss has gone mad
but the top level guys are all loyal to
putin you know guys like bortnikov and
narishkin have of course been with him
for many years going back to the kgb
days um and
i don't see him them moving on him
anytime soon
and
you know i just i just think it's very
very unlikely non-zero but uh close to
zero
and mark can we just touch on before we
finish up um how bad do you think the
crackdown is getting in are going on in
russia i know this week that certain
social media sites being banned in the
country are you getting signs of sort of
increasing authoritarianism that's
building up or do you think we've sort
of reached the plateau with that
oh no um the the depressing truth of the
matter is again i think uh you know to
use dimitri's earlier favor phrase about
going all in i think a decision has been
made that if you're going to go a
certain way towards authoritarianism
then you basically will go the rest of
the way i think we are seeing what for a
long time was it was an interesting kind
of hybrid regime which was
authoritarianism with certain aspects of
constitutionalism and certain aspects in
which they did sort of try and address
certain concerns of of the public and
elections were in some ways almost like
national focus groups in that respect
well i think that's that that's all to
the god we are in this respect in some
ways almost heading back to the 1970s
frankly all the progress that has been
lost and that means that not only will
we see increased attempts to try and
insulate russia from the outside world
in terms of news and information
but at the same time we will see a
growing willingness to use
you know violent methods imprisonment
and such like against people who even
make the mildest of criticisms against
the regime
and we saw this with when putin's most
recent utterances which are quite
extraordinary i mean his tone was
almost stalinist in what he was saying
about the need for a self-cleansing of
society against the traitors and
parasites and so forth we're not heading
to an age of gulags but we are
definitely heading to authoritarianism
but of course the only point i would
make is that
he might want to bring the regime back
to the 1970s but russians are not the
russians of the 1970s they will have
some sense of what they are losing and
again whether that'll bring them out on
the streets or whatever i very much
doubt so long as the security forces
seem loyal and disciplined and willing
to go and crack skulls when need be
but the point is
there will still be a strong anger and
depression i think within society
thank you mark thank you dimitri thank
you very much
in this week's cover story spectator
contributor owen matthews writes about
recep erdogan the turkish president owen
says has found himself as the middleman
between russia and the west but whose
side is he really on owen joins me now
along with hannah lucinda smith a
journalist in istanbul and the author of
erdogan rising the battle for the soul
of turkey
owen and hannah thank you for joining us
on spectator tv
now owen you write in the magazine this
week about how airdiane has sort of
found himself as a
peace broker almost or deal maker when
it comes to putin and the west over the
war in ukraine um to start us off can
you tell us a bit about how eddie and
sort of ended up in this position
well everyone's been in this position
for pretty much his whole career
actually i mean he's he's uh
um he's been uh he's one of the very few
world leaders that actually has been uh
you know described himself as a friend
of vladimir putin's i mean he's uh more
or less uh since the early 2000s he has
sort of cozied up to to to russia and to
putin they've both been in power for 20
years so they know each other very well
um uh and there are very strong economic
links there's a sort of there's a strong
bottom line to erdogan's uh relationship
with uh with putin and that is that uh
turkish companies have done tremendously
well out of a construction boom um in in
in russia um the
they've constructed enormously expensive
pipelines under the black sea and russia
now uh provides um up to 30 percent of
turkey's gas and it's uh uh the russia's
building him uh a set of nuclear power
stations so and and most crucially um
because turkey is of course a member of
nato in 2017 he took an even more
dramatic step and that was that he
bought a very sophisticated russian air
defense system called the x4 s 400 from
putin uh instead of buying uh within
nato and that and that really annoyed
the americans so for a long time despite
um the the uh erdogan's actually sort of
playing both sides against the middle uh
but in fact not just both sides but all
sides i mean because he's uh um
he's also has close economic ties with
ukraine um
most notably um between the company
owned by his son-in-laws seljuk by
rocktile who's actually been supplying
ukrainians with the very deadly and very
effective drones that have been the
surprise sort of um
super weapon of the war
and and hannah when it comes to the
peace process do you think ardian sort
of overstating his diplomatic
credentials of this or do you agree that
he sort of managed to become incredibly
important to the process now
i mean i think you know in in erdogan's
uh ideal world he would be this kind of
mediating figure between you know
warring camps that's what he you know
says that turkey
is or or should be but you know in
reality he is kind of stuck between
these two sides um and although you know
that has come in useful to nato over the
past few weeks you know both sides um
now see him as more useful than he was a
month ago
i think you know from turkey's
perspective it just can't afford to
completely alienate russia we had a bit
of a taste in 2016 of what russia can do
to turkey with really not much very not
much effort at all um so in late 2015
turkey shot down a russian fighter jet
close to the syrian border
and diplomacy completely broke down
putin slapped on uh some embargoes which
included um blocks on turkish
agricultural exports um also stopped
most russian tourists coming to turkey
for holidays in the summer of 2016 and
it had a really massive impact and i
think you know that's going to be
playing in the back of erdogan's mind
i mean in your piece oh and you call
putin and eddie and a bit of a frenemies
almost um what's their relationship like
and
well it's been incredibly stormy i mean
as as hannah says i mean um it's syria
that really i mean it started breaking
down really in 2014 because
um the uh annexation of crimea um
actually uh impacted crimean tatars with
whom turkey um has a sort of an erdogan
in particular because he has a slightly
putin like actually sort of nostalgia
for the ottoman empire and the ottoman
diaspora and the turkish diaspora he had
a sort of kind of proprietary interest
in the fate of the crimean tatars so
that kind of brought them into into into
conflict and erdogan was actually
roundly condemned
putin for that uh for that and but then
things really hit the fan with uh with
syria because in fact um uh as it turned
out the
um assad's forces uh backed by uh by
russian um air power as she started
hitting uh many groups that were
actually affiliated with uh with the
turkish army both actual turkish army
soldiers that were based around in in
inside
syria and iraq and um
also
syrian rebel groups affiliated to
turkmens again like sort of ethnic
nationalists sort of
an interest from erdogan so um syria
actually brought them very close to the
brink and hannah's already talked about
their actual breakdown in relations
which they sort of patched up but um
they're they're kind of uh on on on
again off again friends there there's a
lot that connects them but actually
erdogan
as hannah said um actually doesn't have
a huge amount of room to maneuver
because actually much as the americans
will want him to pick a side at this
week's
nato summit actually he doesn't really
have uh the option of breaking off ties
with putin or uh or of the west he's
he's he's stuck in the middle so in the
in that and in that sense actually that
suits russia because they see erdogan as
an interlocutor but it's also um
a little bit problematic and i think
there's going to be some problems coming
down the pike because the shape of the
ultimate peace negotiation is
essentially going to be uh
putin's face
putin can't withdraw without actually a
solution that allows him to claim
victory
nato cannot allow him to claim victory
that's the catch-22 that we're going to
be dealing with in a few weeks time and
erdogan is in a hurry for strong
economic reasons to actually fix it and
so i think that's really going to be the
debate like is erdogan actually going to
back a face-saving solution that
actually
allows putin to withdraw and claim
victory but which nato is not happy with
and to turn a bit more to the domestic
than hannah erdean's got elections
coming up next year how much are they
going to impact well how much could the
war potentially impact those elections
and and his own position in power
sure well i mean the number one issue
for people in turkey in the lead-up to
elections is the economy a poll after
poll shows it just way out ahead of
anything else um you know inflation is
towards 50
um you can feel it every time you go
into the supermarket here prices rise
almost every day
and wages just aren't keeping up with it
you know people are really really really
struggling and clearly you know the fact
that a lot of turkey's grain comes from
ukraine
um you know the fact that there's
probably not going to be many russian
tourists in turkey this year you know
the tourism sector is a huge part of the
turkish economy it's about 10 13
um and also the threat of further
sanctions which of course uh putin could
slap on turkey again you know i think
that's really really gonna you know
influence erdogan's thinking but
you know here's the thing about erdogan
he's not a sophisticated leader when it
comes to international relations he's
proved himself really really good at
reading the mood of his people
and what he's done over the past five
years particularly is he's often used um
foreign relations for domestic ends so
he's stoke drows with various people
he's stirred anti-americanism he's
stirred sentiment sentiments against the
eu
and closing up to putin has been part of
that
um now the problem now is you know when
you speak to the kind of older
generation of turkish diplomats or
anybody who knows the history of the
region you know turkey and russia are
not natural allies they're natural if
not enemies and adversaries they're
competing powers in the same
neighborhood and you know when you talk
to kind of older diplomats and analysts
and people like that they'll say well
this is what erdogan has forgotten and
you know with all his kind of playing
foreign affairs off against domestic
politics he's now backed into a corner
um so you know i think it's really going
to be a problem for him but you know
domestically you know the number one
thing
is going to be the economy you know
people do have sympathy for the crimean
tatars there's a huge amount of sympathy
here for uh you know the people in
ukraine i think you know on the streets
most people are overwhelmingly kind of
horrified at what russia is doing that
but you know these these things are
secondary if the economy goes even worse
it's going to be really really
disastrous for everyone
and owen going back slightly you
mentioned earlier the birachtar tb2
drones and the sort of the impact
they're having on the war in ukraine at
the moment i'd be very interested to
know what you think and if you thought
that turkey sort of links with ukraine
and supply of the drones was an
intentional stub to russia or do you
think they've just ended up sort of
inadvertently having a semi-influential
position in the wall because of this
uh well i mean they're not supplied by
the turkish government it's a private
company um i mean obviously that's uh
it's a political decision you know who
who you allow your private companies to
sell
arms to but um i mean i think nobody
expected um
not the turks not anyone not even
actually the majority of putin's cabinet
as we now know um i have it on very good
authority from someone very close to
dimitri piskov that during that very
fateful
uh sort of crazy security council
meeting on february 21st uh in which
putin dressed down his uh chief of
foreign intelligence i was on um only
three people in the room were were aware
of the full plan to actually
launch a full-scale invasion so i mean
which is pretty extraordinary it was
putin himself
said
his defense minister alexander bhutnikov
the head of the fsb everyone else was in
the dark so uh you know putin's cabinet
was in the dark zielinski was saying it
wasn't going to happen the turks also
presumed it wasn't going to happen so no
it was not a snub to putin it was just
business uh no one expected that
the the the war to break out on that on
that scale um and already i mean it was
it was talked about because they had
been used a devastating effect by the uh
by the azaris in the
back in the last year so everyone knew
that by reptiles it's uh it's it's it's
sort of strange sort of twist i'm not an
expert in military hardware but
my sources tell me it's sort of
interesting it's an advantage through
sort of a slowness and relative
simplicity strangely enough it's it's
the barrack tiles are effective not
because they're super fast or because
they're super
they have a super sophisticated
communication system they're actually
slow they're propeller-driven and they
have actually sort of been a variable um
you know radio communications that have
managed to sort of brilliantly uh outfox
the russian uh uh
radio
uh defense systems and uh have have
destroyed a lot of russian armor but
they have themselves of course being
destroyed uh in large numbers the
biologicals are being shot down uh and
erdogan is currently refusing to
resupply them or blocking more supplies
so in that sense he's uh um you know
that's another example of his fence
sitting like the the the baroque tiles
have been uh sort of a you know an an
ace in zielinski's arsenal but um so far
he's not getting any more
and there is a family connection isn't
there between the barracktar and
nerdyand how there's quite a close one
if that's right
yeah well uh
the baroque is married to everyone's
younger daughter
it's about as close as you can get might
make awkward family dinners um
hannah um i'd be interested to know your
thoughts on how turkey's sort of
relationship with the west is going and
and how long it can last with them sort
of having a semi-open relationship with
uh with russia
sure well i mean
honestly this this conflict has just
come a really really useful time for
erdogan ever since joe biden took office
uh erdogan's been trying and trying to
kind of work his way back in there with
the west you know
mostly for economic reasons you know
he's talked at home about how he's going
to turn over a new page in relations
with the eu and with the us
and the u.s in particular just hasn't
been that interested um but now clearly
you know
he is useful to the west and
particularly not just useful
actually you know imperative for nato um
so i think you know he's trying to
take full advantage of that um one of
the things that has been reported that
the us is going to ask turkey to do at
the nato conference is to transfer that
russian s 400 missile defense system
that
owen mentioned to ukraine to be used
against russian forces now
i don't think that erdogan's gonna go
that far i think that's really going to
show the limits of any kind of renewed
friendship or renewed loyalty
uh to the west and to the nato alliance
um but yes certainly i mean
in the space of a month this is probably
the best that relations have been
between turkey and particularly america
probably for five years
i know and do you think that balancing
act that turkey is doing at the moment
can last as well
uh well yes um it has to because um um
just as erdogan can't afford if for the
reasons
hannah mentioned um uh to to
uh lose the russian connection neither
can putin lose what the the his
interlocutor i mean
even though erdogan is not really his
friend and they've cleared he's closed
the the the straits the bosphorus and
dardanelles to russian naval traffic and
so on and he's um he's not really a
friend but he's the closest thing to a
friend that um uh that that erdogan
that putin has inside nato so putin
needs him and also as as hannah said
like uh biden and and europe are
suddenly interested in that part of the
world once more so um uh everyone finds
himself in actually sort of a an
unexpectedly strong position that he he
he needs to keep both sides sweet and
both sides need to keep him sweet thank
you wayne thank you hannah
and finally spectator contributor matt
ridley writes in this week's magazine
about china's zero covered strategy the
country is still using draconian
localized lockdowns to keep the virus at
bay will this work matt joins me now
alongside cindy u who hosts the
spectators chinese whispers podcast
cindy and matt thank you for joining us
on spectator tv
now matt to start us off you write in
the magazine this week about china's
zero covert strategy and how things are
going in the country there at the moment
can you start off by telling us a little
bit about the situation there
yes well it appears that uh the omicron
variant particularly this new ba dot 2
variant of omicron which is more
infectious
is spreading very rapidly in hong kong
and shenzhen and probably now in the
rest of china too
it looks unlikely that china will be
able to maintain its policy of
preventing the the spread of covid um
simply by public health measures uh and
that it'll have to go to another
strategy this is very worrying for china
because there's a huge population there
it's not fully vaccinated
including the elderly in in hong kong in
particular there's been quite a lot of
elderly people who've not been
vaccinated and who have been
um quite badly affected by this virus so
i think china is facing a serious
covered waves two years after sort of
telling us rather triumphantly and
opening a museum in wuhan to the effect
that it had conquered kovid and
taught the rest of the world how to do
so um and just to be clear matt are you
saying that the zero coverage strategy
is no longer viable
i think the xero covered strategy is not
viable in any country i mean new zealand
and australia and other countries kept
up a zero kovid policy at some huge cost
for a long time but they did at least
use that time to develop vaccines or
other to to
inoculate people with vaccines
and
that meant that once they effectively
abandoned their zero covert strategy
which countries like australia are now
effectively doing
it wasn't going to be too bad but i
think it's unlikely any country will be
able to pursue a zero coverage strategy
from now on because of the highly
infectious nature of the ba2 variant of
the omicron variant of the virus which
spreads pretty stealthily you know
you're infectious before you know it etc
and cindy do you agree that the virus is
impossible to control at this stage in
china
well i think um the where differ with
matt is that i think the xero cover
policy has many problems but ineffective
it is not uh by which i mean the chinese
call it dynamic zero covered so the
problem is not having cases per se but
the dynamic uh nature of it so said so
they say it's me what it means is that
uh any covert cases are clamped down
very very quickly now omicron obviously
presents a very unique and unprecedented
challenge in that because it is just so
infectious but at the same time the
chinese lock down the xero cover policy
is nothing like we can imagine here in
the west when how strict it is and that
is why i think it will still work so
just taking a look at what it means on
the ground
if you have covered in china right now
you'll be taken off to a centralized
quarantine center and if you have severe
illness you'll be taken to hospital but
you're no one is allowed to have covert
at home and certainly you're not allowed
to have covered with anyone else any of
your contacts and even contact of
contacts of positive cases are being
taken to these centralized quarantine
areas as well tested regularly and if
any of them develop uh covert they are
then taken to a separate place um my
mother she's just gone to china last
week she's for foreign people go for
foreigners going into china you now have
to take three pcr tests before going
into the country and then you're going
to put through weeks of hotel quarantine
for higher two weeks depending on where
you're landing and then one week of home
quarantine so that's the kind of
hermetic seal that the chinese have put
on this um and and by the way any city
that's found with covet cases everyone
has gone through mass testing so you
know it's not a symptomatic uh you can
get a test or anything like that every
single person is instructed to get three
tests a week so that's the kind of
massive state infrastructure that is
being put into place and i think the
problems with the xero cover policy are
many fold up for example matt as matt
mentioned how do you get out of it you
know without vaccination what is the
future for that and i think that's the
biggest problem and then the other
problem is the massive state funding
that's going into all of this i think
it's estimated that last summer in one
of the guangzhou flats it was one
billion dollars spent just on testing
alone you know so those are the kind of
numbers that we don't normally get to
see on the outside but we'll be costing
chinese coffers so i think those are the
problems but i don't think that zero
cover policy is failing insofar as it
looks unsuited to be treating omicron
but it's also going to be saving lives
at the end of the day just because the
chinese state is just putting so much
money into the system
and matt how much do you think china's
problems are down to the vaccine roll up
there can you tell us a bit about that
well
china did develop a vaccine very early
on uh
it is widely regarded in most of the
world as being not as effective as the
western vaccines and they haven't
allowed the western vaccines in so i
think there is a real problem uh in that
um
you know the vaccines aren't all that
brilliant even in the west because they
don't prevent transmission uh now
um they do prevent serious disease
so if you have an even less effective
vaccine and you know the reason for not
letting pfizer and other firms
sell their vaccines into china seems to
be a degree of sort of pride and
protectionism which i think is a mistake
um so i do think that that's an issue
but one of the just to pick up on
what cindy said which is very very
interesting um
one of the things that i'm concerned
about is the degree to which we in the
west were told that we should model our
public health measures against kovid on
the chinese
model
there was a lot of praise of china early
on having got it right etc and i don't
think that should be allowed to pass you
know
at this moment when we now know that you
know we couldn't have had as draconian a
lockdown as cindy described in the west
and that's what would be necessary to
have a zero covet policy in the west
elimination
i think was impossible once
uh it had got out of wuhan and into the
rest of the world we now know
yes i absolutely agree matt i mean
lockdown you know we use the same word
to describe what we went through here in
the uk and what china is going through
now but it is really not the same thing
at all you know people in china have
very little recourse to change policy
you know there are no lock down skeptics
on the public sphere for obvious reasons
um and you know we've had situations
where if you're in disneyland you know a
place that holds tens of thousands of
visitors someone else has positive on
the day that you go you're locked down
in disneyland for hours until you can
get tested and released you know that's
the kind of civil liberties erosion that
is not at all possible here as much as
we rail against lockdown in a western
format already
and matt do you think china's troubles
now have made lockdowns less likely in
the west i mean you mentioned in your
piece the fact that neil ferguson said
he got sort of the inspiration for
lockdown from from china do you think
that sort of undermined the case for
lockdowns more broadly
i think that
you know a lot of us thought lockdowns
probably were necessary right at the
start i certainly took that view
but i quite quickly began to realize as
professor mark woolhouse of edinburgh
university has spelled out in his book
the year the world went mad
that lockdowns are designed to eliminate
the virus
they don't work for simply um
controlling the spread of the virus
you know
they either
they can buy you a bit of time that's
for sure but
once you
realize that you can't eliminate the
virus in three
weeks or three months or something
then you've got to find a policy that
enables you to live with the virus for
two or three years and two or three
years of lockdowns are not acceptable
the
mental cost the physical cost the
health cost the economic cost on the
population is simply too high i think
we've learned that lesson i think we
were right to open up in july in 2021
and again not to lock down in december
2021 when most of the
public health experts were urging the
government to do so
yes we had an omicron wave in january
but it did not result in a significant
increase in deaths and hospitalizations
at least nothing like what was predicted
by some
and so um we are now in a position where
in the uk
and much of the rest of the west we can
get back to living normally while having
the occasional very bad cold um called
covid i just had that myself two weeks
ago um it's no fun but it's not uh
life-threatening and we have to be able
to to to live like that while of course
you know making special
efforts to protect the most vulnerable
people
well i'm glad you're feeling better matt
um
cindy uh matt touched on there sort of
the economic cost of this for china i'd
be interested to hear your thoughts on
how big do you think that will be i mean
we've seen some big cities like shanghai
and shenzhen going to lockdown recently
do you think china's gonna have a big
economic hit this year from the sort of
zero covered fallout
so earlier this month china had another
one of these chinese communist party
meetings called the two sessions and
there the vice pre the premier league
town announced china's gdp figure for
this year or target for this year 5.5
which sounds like a lot to us um but for
china that's the lowest in three decades
so the chinese authorities even you know
on the outset are making clear that
they're not expecting the economy to not
take a hit this year um and we also saw
last week presidency make this
commitment to more transparency in
regulation in the stock market which
made the stocks go up again because they
recognize that the economy needs a bit
of a boost but a lot of the costs we
just don't simply see you know we don't
see the aviation uh damage of you know
if you might think back to pre-clover
times the chinese were super
cosmopolitan you know because of
globalization they were traveling
everywhere there was trade going
everywhere a lot of that has gone now
you know someone like my mother going
home has to
do three pcr tests to get there and the
tickets are not easy to come by either
so that all of that will have an
economic cost and in china as well there
are 300 million informal workers people
without contracts who overnight can see
their jobs get lost um if they're
unlucky enough to be in a city who that
was locked down um overnight so all of
these things will have costs but i think
china
thinks that with a zero cover policy if
it's one city at a time that goes down
and then they normally expect that
within a month at least with delta you
could get rid of those local infections
omicron it might take longer at least
that means other cities can still thrive
in the meantime you know this kind of
community infection would they believe
have more disruption and i guess you
know zero covert has you can criticize
it for many reasons but on saving lives
if that is your only narrow metric it is
doing quite well
do you agree with that matt has it been
a success in that sense
yes i think you can't deny that uh
draconian lockdowns have saved lives um
i think there's only really two policies
that have saved lives during this
pandemic one is locked dance and the
other is vaccines
i don't myself believe that masks and
school closures and other you know many
of the other things have worked well or
indeed you know
disinfecting our hands etc we now know
that wasn't necessarily good advice i
think it's worth
it's worth just being a bit humble here
this virus has been humiliating for
um
a lot of people it's been humiliating
for public health uh advice often not
necessarily getting it right early on or
even later on during the pandemic it's
been humiliating for politicians in
terms of what measures they can take etc
and as cindy says it's been humiliating
for a
huge nation that was opening up to the
world and has now had to turn itself
back into a bit of a hermit kingdom
which cannot be good for the world um it
is cutting chinese people off from
uh the rest of the world that's bad for
them and bad for us um
much as the war is doing for russia
so it does feel like a very different
world from five years ago
that we're now living in with these um
rather dramatic balkanizations of
the the global body politic
that's a really interesting point and
cindy i know xi jinping states a lot of
his international reputation on how well
china handled the virus the beginning of
the pandemic is that starting to sort of
crumble away a bit now and affect his
own leadership do you think
yeah i mean
there are people within china who are
ever so slightly starting to crack
through you know this this veneer of
zero-covered um zeitgeist you know
people are able to now come out and say
well maybe we should think about the
next steps and the reason china has been
so slow on doing that is exactly as you
say john that xi jinping has made this
part of his political legacy after the
initial humiliation of the wuhan
outbreak she was saying you know we've
got the ppe we've got the lockdowns and
we've got the vaccine diplomacy well on
all three of those things there are
things that criticisms one can make of
it and especially on the zerekova policy
it's become such a political point that
you can't help but realize that the
politicians in china are not following
the science
and are really just you know embarrassed
to turn around and they're realizing
that they're too slow intriguingly we
are seeing signs that
there is more allowance of discussion of
the next steps so for example one
shanghai epidemiologist jamming hong
this time last year said that we might
want to live with kovet he got
absolutely pilloried online
these days when he says some of
something similar you know people online
are allowed to say that you know have
more diverse views so you do wonder the
changing position of censors in that
respect and i think china hopes that
lockdowns for it has been a time buying
mechanism as matt was saying and it
hopes that by the end of this year they
can develop its own mrna vaccines and
that it can have very good anti-virals
which it has already approved a few of
including from pfizer actually
under emergency approvals so it's hoping
that it can medicate its way out of the
situation with better medication than
just its vaccines at the moment um and
until then it just has to basically buy
time and the question is does that still
work with omicron
and that what cost because the cost is
getting ever higher the more contagious
the variants become
i mean as a final point you mentioned in
your piece that the west should perhaps
be doing more and sending millions of
doses of our vaccines to china um i
guess it comes down to a question of
pride do you think china will accept
that gift
um
i think it's unlikely i think um
the the
chinese pride is very involved here and
the
it it would have to be a perfectly
commercial arrangement look we've got
vaccines now we probably don't need to
put forth boosters into most
people's arms uh in the west um why
won't you
take these
there has been such a strong tendency in
chinese biotech in particular
to
see western technology as something you
want to learn from you want to emulate
and you then want to
replace with your own technology that i
think it isn't an easy moment for the
chinese government to say
actually please could you help us
but it would be
sensible i think if they did that um and
just another point if i may uh
if
um
you know we cannot open up again to
travel from china for a long time
that will prevent chinese scientists
particularly from wuhan
coming to the west and
giving us useful bits of information
that might enable us to solve the
enduring puzzle of where this virus came
from and how it jumped into human beings
in the first place something we still
haven't solved and we're getting very
very little cooperation from the chinese
government in tackling
thank you matt and thank you cindy
and if you want to listen to cindy's
podcast you can find chinese whispers
and all the usual podcast platforms or
at spectator dot code uk forward slash
whispers
that's it for this week
once again we're delighted that
canaccord genuity wealth management is
sponsoring the week in 60 minutes
cold will provide the expertise you need
to build your wealth with confidence you
can visit candu wealth.com to find out
more
and if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you